time for another sweaty afternoon on the
chair jolly podcasters the sweatiest
mandarine all right now hawala could see
a manatee lawrence are you - no the
sweaty man taught in the air spoil
austin where arch is elise liked it tell
everyone but we don't want anyone known
because it's like a really cheap I don't
the red school it was people more to
know me but it's it's in like a
bombshell er Lucio World War two bunker
basically what was the toilet I knew you
subtle there the restroom yeah pretty
great this place Jeremy independent I
don't have fund and yet welcome it is
different where we had the last time
what was generally I didn't mean ask you
because I'm really support any much
sense because unfortunately we live at
opposite ends of the country so I only
get to have a chat with you when we're
doing [__] like this did you get much
reaction from coming on the podcast last
time that many people say I'm not sure
so I obviously the thing is like your
audience obviously some of them detest
me like fully no matter what doing about
was alright though man I like them like
yeah alright so I go ahead disposed need
someone I usually yeah wait even all my
reasons behind everything you an adult
color lawrence attorney is a type of guy
to slap his own ass in yet the video and
said hose on your video yeah why would
you lose your insects were chicken the
chicken over yeah yeah but yeah but
other than that i it was good obviously
this sort of podcast gives people trying
to sort of see people and youtubers more
in depth and i think i love you will
learn a lot about me through that yeah
yeah uh i respect with what you said
that you really sort of you just didn't
hold back at all midsole as per let's do
this again yeah yeah you look and make
your being working out you got this box
and much coming up yes obviously feel
bigger
yeah just announced confirmed myself
open co in a boxing match obviously
people already saying our CEO is gonna
get battered all that stuff when it's a
favorite but i honestly I I don't know
what to expect from him because in sport
he's always surprised me since like they
and obviously we don't because he
shouldn't be good at football like when
you talk to him you wouldn't expect them
to be good at football
no but then you get him on the pitch and
he's very coordinated so but
where is another thing that I haven't
thought of which is keeping me head
could we talk about this on this podcast
under the light and under pressure you
freeze a lot of the time you do you even
admit I day died inside no yes no but
every time I do everything evil he
doesn't like the Wembley cooked last
time he was like the best youtuber gall
of all time really so maybe he's gonna
he's going to deliver and you're gonna
freeze another dies entirely correct
I couldn't well yeah he's not you're
supposed to give it the big eye but a
little bit of thing is it's like I can't
deny it that is my biggest bountiful
like the second nose pressure not
overthink it and he's amazing at dealing
with it so we bought one of those in a
source in some you know it's just is it
safe for this field you know ways that
simple I mean you said surprises
straight it's a straightforward case
Euripides right yeah yeah you're the MIR
whether you're the favorite he's the
MacGregor in this area yeah in a sense
of like yeah the pressure is almost
because when everyone's saying are you
should win so easily there's actually
more pressure there's more pressure on
mayweather to win then there is mcgregor
well there is a bit this is a bit of
this is playful what but there is a bit
of this that's quite serious as well
between these because I've heard you say
things about each other you know yeah on
Friday he did see that you changed a bit
yeah everyone is know when you were
doing that trailer on camera how much of
that was you to just sort of getting
stuff out that yeah don't get me wrong
everything that was said in that trailer
is honest and I'm being serious when I
say that like need like we've had we
have had these forts and it's like but
we make do we like make something of it
play on it and like you know make a
YouTube scene out of it or do we just
keep it behind closed doors you know
some sort you'll obviously it well in my
opinion you should always be minutes but
there is like with any friendship the
times where you just want to but other
[__] out of each other I mean me and
Lawrence have had those moments yeah in
Barcelona yeah I'm thinking to myself
thought is any of this just coincide
with the fact that Elliott is now when
available now he's off with MTV and you
need someone else to make videos part of
it now he's definitely even max what's
going to know that mean please no
ironically drop you so you've got a no
pickpocket with the old guy
we're doing but I could see just a
slightly different skin tone any yeah
yeah because I was like it's doing MTV
and then the very next week and say oh
joy hey with my deal again it's funny
how that works
yeah I know that basally is that weave
my god it's a season I got together with
yeah yeah we just what did you get off
at the MTV thing cuz up and then if you
reject you oh surely that was a knockout
in the joy I know I'm never a do-over no
no you didn't get off of the empty
reason no no so Elliott got that well
yeah I think you have we sort of left
issue but as it left behind nan and I so
I got that remarried but the thing is I
like I thought you took them from
Starbucks and now he's off with MTV
thing and Georgia one from McDonald's
you took one from Starbucks party the
coffee if somebody goes to coffee now
going I just hope that you're walking
because I'm updated when your drive back
to South Coast tonight you're just going
to be calling and it could be he's like
making millionaires yeah didn't mean
he's humping in them right yeah we've
given it aliens Dale is big but I'm
scared like I'm glad like it's good to
see obviously when you start making
videos with someone who's just gone from
give up working in Starbucks they like
he looked a lot different when you look
at the early videos between Joe and
earlier yeah he looked a lot different
than angels no I'm glad that he's now
going off and doing his own thing like
and making things for himself he's grown
a lot yeah you feel quite proud when you
see him doing this yeah yeah yeah like
it obvious important to keep like a
level head and not let not let it get to
ah to your heads do you think that might
be an issue
like what no I'm just asking the guys I
like I'm here for though I just think I
just think it's good that he's clearly
taking the opportunities get given and
likewise I feel like he's getting he's
getting nice time to really make a
career for himself like you said yeah
he's gonna get you saved a hashtag
United's you're on his football skills
oh yeah staying fit unfortunately for
you is regularly training yeah I suppose
fitness coming for you that's the thing
I'm trying my best but obviously we said
we're doing no boxing training right
lean up to it
that's oddly opposite of morph - yeah
but because like because I see a lot of
times hundreds and stuff like it like
really something I may be able to get
more training than him being with
hashtag and stuff so it's just like we
going you know what let's nirav us do
boxing training just do fitness then
again can you really trust them like
what if one of them's like oh yeah but
then he's read Brittany Hutton and then
eternity comes in in just the perfect
shot is arriving I like right I'm
trusting him but yeah yeah I mean that
also makes it a little bit more like a
natural fight doesn't it a bit more like
you know a real strong on the inside
yeah like maybe the more scrappy you may
be of it at the same time the other
thing that we don't want to just make it
so it's just some little freezer like
now we want to hopefully bring some
actual technical ability and have a
proper you sure young men training
because the way you hold your hands up
just make you look like you've been
doing some training this is the natural
things fall into that position right
Holly yeah India five always say I was
the yes camp UNIX Benton yes school but
like that apart that lazy I've never not
proper training okay any receive so it
should be interesting
okay because he's quite coordinated with
feet like you say I wonder if you can
match you with understand so have you
seen any of what Elliot's done on MTV
yeah what's the concept that there is
like basically the single guys looking
for a girl now he's never let's be
honest he's never going to have a
problem with that before is he really
looking to basket I mean looking at the
amazona yeah I mean MTV really could
have gone for someone who's sort of you
know a bit low down the pecking order
you know I mean like bloke who just you
know he made maybe one of the YouTube
maybe on the twitch guys who does find
it hard you know what I mean somebody
sort of seen home and one of those who
followed so just thought was plucks all
the time yeah you know yeah said they
were so guy well just they went for the
guy who's just hanging out around LA
anyway like was I mean we've all seen an
Instagram mmm
you've got the hard signs down and all
ya got the nice cool chair as well alone
yeah yeah yeah not like the truth I mean
like really City I assume what's
happened is he's you know had the
interview he's they'll be looking for
people that are willing to put
themselves out there
yeah and find like I'll see everyone on
the show I mean that those Jedward yeah
everyone's like pretty Accenture
I can I wouldn't take risk in order is
this adventure is it the undateable is
what I'd really don't know I don't know
where everyone just made spits though
okay
or whether what we can go for that
Marnie from Jordan oh he doesn't know
and that's the thing like look basically
you can reveal a little to me let Elliot
PR look at basically so you know not
where you see Ed you know I can't say
this nation can i well say it and we'll
decide that you can say okay oh now like
you'll see you see the stuff that like
gets put on social media are
littlewiggle these girls but there's
difference between like actually being
with all these girls and saying girls
can we take a picture for my Instagram
you not I mean
sure oh yeah sorry yeah yeah I'm I'm not
a longer so what of the line right
everyone good Instagram shot yeah but
it's not like I mean you've still got to
get to the pool you suppose we get those
girls into the kitchen right in your
head your eyes dan Bilzerian with always
blows every I mean if we're completely
on time when we time bill Terry you know
how close to Dan Joey what you are me
yeah nowhere near okay
I love bear models in there I mean yeah
I don't mean morally and the thing is
the thing is that we're not talking
about the elephant in the room which is
for most of the summer
I'd be receiving snap chat from Chewelah
a naked you want oh yeah like rocking up
with his cocoa and girls in the back
well and their pants up at the end of
account so nobody but you've got a good
some other lesbians why you Oliver I've
had a good summer
yeah again and Joe Hotel everyone
ghettos were staged or buddies but you
ask the girl might not have been boxing
but you've had some big hits or so yeah
you know but obviously we you've had a
good summer
yeah I'm glad you're out there celebrate
like when you leave home for the first
time not as great obviously reason we
had their youtuber trip to magaluf mmm
struggling no no no no that was good we
obviously like meeting up with boys and
stuff and who's the boy side man - Julie
case I the burn chip jmx fever and
Elliot like calling the burn ship Navin
okay yeah I get tips funny as [__] yeah
it's cheers Cheers Chloe we all had a
great laugh and I yeah and I it has been
a fun summer it's been good
I remember I got one text I'm not going
to say exactly what you said but he was
struggling to make it home with you me
Wow what far contain this letter I'm
proud of them you know I mean this all
you should be doing when you're young
like you're growing up now you're not
trying to eat well you're going to the
questions that's the problem the board's
hell yeah oh come here
yeah maybe use it McDonald's bag all of
it yeah yeah so you like trouble and
where he traveled in the past year so
it'd been to Los Angeles how long were
you in LA for it look like you're in LA
where we were two three week period okay
what's that a close together basically
we were filming me and Elliot were
filming these music videos for these
songs we've done really she did some
light just we did some rap songs we did
the hold it in the haunted homes we did
all of that and and the thing is is like
we've gone over there we've filmed with
this guy that the dancers and everything
though you have some young girls he's
not given us the face like the Geezer
that we film with he's straight-up just
we did always work and he's refusing my
aha moment none of that he wants to edit
it but this kid like he's obviously got
so much work they can't do it and we
need it out now and it's one of the
things that doesn't just give us the
fries because I get until then you can
edit yourself yeah well that's what I
want to do I'm like it's an appointment
I'll do anything to be able to just edit
ourself but like that's something that
people don't really get a side of when
there's YouTube fun is that the
struggles and the [__] frustration of
having to work with dicks like that do
you ever just want to flip in take
matters into your own hands
yeah man and that is why late she like
like whenever I can I'd do it myself but
I hate relying on people obviously like
I have my my friends my straight friends
I can rely on but like Pete like
professionally rely on people it's just
it's so risky but is it like fair enough
with flexible a little bit we wanted
these songs out of the beginning of
summer but imagine if we literally
needed like in there if that's when I
did my World Cup song imagine if all the
World Cups finished by the time you're
ready like you know what I mean or if
you got a brand-new relying on you
scales are out there or at the same time
I think most people take for granted
that you guys are invested time and
money in that let you mess with it I
guess yeah
you don't get that nice happen I was and
I was creating music yeah yeah like
going out there and stuff and it's just
is frustrating but like I how'd you feel
that song did like the mean something
that you resist mission now obviously
the main issue with that one was I
uploaded it released it and I'm
foolishly and I'll be myself focus on my
finish but I've accidentally submitted
the version where the vocals weren't as
prominent as they needed to be so I had
to take it down now obviously everyone
who'd purchased that first version
didn't purchase the one when I
resubmitted so it means it didn't chart
as well as it could have it was rising
it because even if the the last song
that you want to do yes that did [__]
really well all of the course and I mean
they I couldn't believe how like you
literally crossed over yeah all the DJ's
were playing at their ism yeah is that
somewhere where you want to keep on
pursuing you want to do more and more
music because I've seen JJ like he's now
just full-blown going into music are you
so I'm doing main thing and something
I'm definitely not per my eggs in one
basket a moment I'm lazy just gonna
ideally keep on with the music
I keep might have a news open because
I'm still young I don't want fully clear
sight yet I'll do a 21 something new
you're so you're like this I just wanted
like chemo avenues overnight they would
love making like a decent team yeah yeah
all right well what do you reckon of
judges they break from YouTube and
letting him go on into music
well obviously the thing is is like I
feel like what he's experienced I've had
exactly the same thing I think so many
youtubers has that transition where you
obviously he started at the age about 16
to that transition of growing up and
realize like your interest and
everything that you want to do changes
but you've built up an audience that
expects something that you you have to
make yeah explain something that you
used to make that you no longer like
doing and the pressure in that and like
that
everything that Sutton about how he's
dealt with it is one actually going away
and withdrawing himself he can afford to
yeah look at it but it is a bit weird
that isn't it because the human brain
were not really evolved that far from
when we were just in foot in in the
woods [__] hunting for food
and YouTube has pretty [__] then well
yeah I'm just saying like we're still of
that mind state almost so like now if
you're a knight in your lad and you've
got like millions of followers who also
make a video like that and then do what
you've always done like it is a bit of a
weird thing to go through I guess I mean
I suppose a lot of people would say
that's pretty sociable problems out you
know I mean I'm just saying it's weird
yeah and maybe seven more yeah yeah hard
it's just weird so some people don't
really have the knowledge to deal with
it I guess it's also it can feel a
little bit like you you obviously want
to change or you can't help the fact
that your interests change you know you
can't sort of I want to remain you know
interesting you go cards forever or
whatever some of us do but you're
interesting and then people are saying
to your child don't change as a person
because it can feel like quite a
personal relation I know it definitely
feels like they're saying like you're
not as good as you used to be I think
you get a start I think I think you get
that more than a lot of you really I
think if not the most but they
criticized you too but I've seen where
like you had to do a few videos now I
think you did one not long ago where you
would just say look me like this is the
[__] reason anyway yeah exactly sort
of generally you're just sick of hearing
the same thing over a long and I hate
that I hate it like that video there
would there be boy inside me for months
and I was like no I don't want to
address essentially god I just want to
be positive positive positive I don't
want to address negativity like if I
only upload about once every two weeks
as it is I thought it'd be this yeah
okay so I it is annoying but it was
either point out like I I need to
Express
it's just like but still like even in
line no one why do you listen well love
you why do you think it is that you get
more [__] than all the other youtubers
are dying there's only when you look at
the other youtubers and you're looking
yourself do you feel like you I don't
know there's a reason for it like why do
you get to try a bit differently because
I really think you do actually ah
is it because I maybe I portray a sense
of confidence like I don't know maybe
I'm I don't know some people may I think
some people have got this image is
because you act like a bit of dust
flower but like you
bitte copy and people have bring copy
people donor egg but it can also go the
opposite way though because a lot of
other youtubers maybe don't go as
personal as you do they go my personal
and if you reveal sort of a more
vulnerable side there are going to be
people who will go for it because you
see it not be that right I can go for
that because you do the video where you
talk from the whole whereas a lot of
youtubers still ignore the negativity
angle alright we're going to do another
playthrough of this game that would play
the next episode and they'll ignore it
whereas I think they know if they
criticize you you will actually everyone
wait actually quite interesting but it
was a good thing as well yeah like in
your videos where you have been either
angry or sort of had to have a catch-up
or chat or whatever you haven't done
that normal sort of thing that youtubers
do where they go into a white room and
things aren't again there brother go
well it's plain-looking I so talk about
let's do hype it up and I've been
avoiding this a two-year well yeah well
that usually just like live on the
burden is like look I've got a lot of
very wheels in the way of getting them
he's trying to chat but it was and
credit to quite human
yeah which makes it almost a bit more
real than the other people who staged
this sort of you didn't get link cry you
know thankfully yeah now I just try to
keep it real at all the times I like
this idea but I'm let's just don't
normally like the kids that started
there's a kid it was at school I'm
exactly the same much simpler then be
honest then do you still have a passion
for YouTube as a platform okay so here
you go right basically I will always
love making videos for an audience
please in a video please in an audience
to making something that will always
give me the best feeling but I think the
actual like the the type of audience
that comes with YouTube can get a little
bit like like the people I sniffles
explain they put like the good people
like things with a good motive to but I
did that the complete like no beds so
just constantly giving the same [__] and
that just morons right it just gets to a
point where like I don't even want to
give my energy justify myself to you
like why like why should I make a video
for you alright like I don't give a [__]
about you you're a bigot but the problem
is and I totally understand what you're
saying because every youtuber has those
people yeah in the audience
okay well yeah like when you leave those
are dead joke is not funny yeah it like
you know is but when you say that it
come people who are muscle fun - yeah
they make the think as you're talking
about me yeah I get that and you can
come across badly so my mother I
understand already been figure anyway
where people sort of misinterpreted what
your mouth do all the time I always I
say like I certainly say something like
that comes across anything also not
really gets amplified because people
actually want people want to fight you
know they one of the are Joe's actually
a bit of a wanker I want to trip you up
not like there are a lot of people that
are waiting for you'd sort of my
father's love to see them as I go to
[__] it all up but that look especially
did they want to see everyone is big on
YouTube far they want to see anyone
who's got over a million followers throw
it all away give it to me because people
time its massive views for them they've
got Joe Weller in your title in a video
it's going to help them the fact is you
know there are very few people you can
remain respectable and talk about
tittle-tattle stuff like so you do think
your main criticism is you've changed
because of the deserve the criticism
that's that's a [__] observation that
someone said angrily do you know what I
mean I think it's because I mean I don't
I'm not like think about a lot of my old
videos with only so far over the top we
were young kid yeah yoga kids well yeah
so as you go to a lot of people I may
have got more boring for some other
people obviously I don't make the type
of videos that I used to in that 10
things we all did when we went to the
bus stop I thought I'd rather be [__] I
was give you them man that I haven't
actually I was in a cage whatever video
below still are I to you that yeah I
think it just kind of get in order like
you want to talk about more real-life
[__] and you have different locations so
a lot of kids that's just boring and
it's just it's fact it just is right and
that's why I like the haunting stuff
because it's a real like a real sense of
a real sense of what we've done that
goes with a black it's a real sense of
like adrenaline on all my god and I'll
say I'm done with the like the show the
YouTube are only in its hair
entertainment when I shut up or what
would be Frank real I think actually I'm
seeing a lot of youtubers sort of swear
towards up more a bit like I think
they're all
we're seeing a lot of youtubers going to
grow up at the same time and I think
they're all getting a bit bored of what
they used to do but some are too - heads
into the gravy train that they can't get
off it so we've seen people make gradual
transitions and then there's some people
who've never will make that transition
because that they know that this is all
I can do some people are forced to make
that transition because they they stop
earning money from their videos yeah and
suddenly they get pretty desperate like
the food offer you want for example
you're probably quite fortunate that
actually you didn't it's nothing to do
with money see you essentially on
YouTube it's not like it's like you know
you're trying to make all those millions
and hold it like what you you want to do
is you got creatively frustrated all
other thing like what if I'm not
creatively like productively doing me
like that is what I'm getting my lowest
line and into that is the main thing but
that's healthy for you the way that you
think about your creative process have
you ever spoken to anyone about just
getting rid of that and like actually
trying it because it sounds a lot like
you attach your creativity a lot to you
know being happy or sad or sort of being
like a bit low but or do you do using as
healthy for either of you or something
like mm-hmm
I don't think it is buying good choice
right slightly sure it's just it is what
it is okay I I think that's where you
time to reflect about what's your
purpose and I think mine is to entertain
and create but it's just finding what
like what like the mixture of like
trying new tea liquids imagine like
every time you try something new well
it's running out of ideas doing like
trying new things is running out without
yeah yeah is funny but I guess with what
you're most proud of now this ah okay um
the recent trailer that we did me and
faeo I enjoyed making that name is
bringing out my filmmaker side again I
know it's quite as simple it's nothing
too technical I was sick like that when
I was not sure why it was just so I was
like that and yet again that's something
a bit more saying are not being a
filmmaker satisfy my more mature thing
to say bit more boring in the eyes are a
lot of kids you're not I'm interesting
and I've asked out some side it just is
some of them hungover I don't know some
people kind of want to hold on
that valium loud that they knew and just
don't happen it but it's not that that's
the way the thing isn't it yeah yeah
Joella in some people's main will be the
kid round the corner who made youtube
videos in their head that's the way they
related to you yeah and you get an order
and you're going to go into a [__] ton
of more things in the next five years
who [__] knows but like going and
potentially notes or anything to go but
I mean yeah I don't go a lot so if I'm
going inside they don't want you to go
off and make films or whatever I make
more music they want you to do they want
able to pin you down I suppose yeah yeah
I mean that's the thing I'm not saying I
want you to go off and think film stuff
but as a thing like comedy is like the
main thing I love it like make people
laugh and stuff it's just [__] like
what way am I going to make people love
because it's all about progression in it
and I think like the idea right now is
guy making a video like that you know
the classic old whatever videos are made
I'd rather do anything else I had that
I'd be angry with film in it I'm sure
those videos that you've made where you
feel like I've got to make this because
it could be good but like you're hating
yeah I'm not I've made videos where I
look at them right after Moghuls god
what a playlist [__] that is I'm not
putting that on like you know when you
talk about that emotional thing like a
few weeks ago we did interview was an
undercover police officer on the podcast
and I at the end of it went away and I
thought he was this guy was great
Barr thought I was absolutely [__] in
that interview because I was so tired
and I had not all incident have been
traveling and I was absolutely [__]
wrecked and I thought I could have been
so much better they're like I don't
think I was here it literally I was
pissed off for a good day or two about
it because I thought I could have made
that so much so I know exactly what you
mean when you say like it governs your
emotions like if you're if you've got a
creative video and you think people are
going to [__] love this this is a
great idea like I'm so buzzing about
this like I'm literally feeling I've got
the best job in the world they can just
feel like the luckiest man yeah I really
like I'm so [__] lucky to do this and
then this day is where if I don't do
something good I just really I feel like
[__] yeah I do get like that as well
yeah might not lady 100% I think exactly
what about it's almost like mmm you make
something good it's like a
injection of like what he has or what
drugs
dudes right but just feel like that well
if the drug is like it's like a high it
is like a harder yeah but I guess that's
why like I don't know like music
musicians a bit like on us most like
when you put a great album together
something that can only imagine what the
most hope and feel like I think though
that creative process changes as you get
older because actually like when you're
16 you're you don't have it you don't
necessarily have taste for all those
things you know what I mean like it you
like it sends it with food or drink or
anything like that when you're 16 you
just like or food or you like or drink
or whatever and then as you get older
you sort of develop that palette and as
you do that it also makes it more
difficult to become creative but you
become more critical of yourself as well
so by the time Kanye West is 40 he's
probably not going to look back at the
college dropout and be like he'll admire
it but I might knew that I'd do
different yeah yeah how critical of
yourself or you just are too much I'm
CATIA man I like so bad like even if I
do something good that like I'm good
I'll let you be like what is it [__] so
I'm not enjoying that I die
how'd you judge that I have to get
friends if I forget I have to ask me one
girl honestly tell me because I over N
is it is like I'll take but for normally
what would take someone like a few hours
off K 23 days because I'm like
perfectionist like I have to get
everything completely correct and by
that point I'm like I must submit since
work on the Florence because I knew you
before I was doing like regular podcast
for him but I always knew that like when
when Joel records your likes to have his
mates around and stuff like that and
you're like a people person and I before
then it just been me and becoming like a
little bit like what you started off
doing real names and that infant leader
bed and when I started recording me him
I sort of realized I kind of understood
why you did that because if you're
having an off day someone else can sort
of pick you up but also it is good to
get that feedback as I mean there's a
lot of times where I'll send in videos
and be like this ship me a lot because I
just I've looked at it I've edited it
for like two [__] years and now I've
just got no idea what's going on so they
watch gym video so yeah [__] all I
did that cheering so I get what your
survey said it it was it was that's what
you need those you need someone that is
you they say that like you know
when you submit your essay or you press
like upload on a video sometimes you get
that feeling like it isn't right
I should like I almost wish there was
like a way you could just like you could
rewind five minutes do you know what I
mean you could just get I wouldn't
upload this right now and give yourself
a little bit more time because there's a
feeling you get after you complete it
when you look back you can make
everything in video change in a certain
way from my point of view as a fan of
your videos now that Paul Harley admit
I'm like a genuine fan of what you've
done especially when I first started
watching I was like this kid [__] get
it like big-time lately
until the feel video like a big for the
last few months maybe this like this
year I just felt like watching the
videos like you are in love with this
the way you were and I say that as a fan
is admit like and I don't mean that as a
critic I can just feel like I can tell
when you're genuine we've talking in the
last podcast about you listen to an
album from an artist
and you can tell some albums like your
favorite music artist they were in love
with this they made this this was the
[__] like this is the best thing that
you put up they threw themselves into
this and like other albums later on
maybe they like you kind of doing this
because it's your job now in it and I
don't mean that as a dig at year but the
feel video I was like nah he's [__]
buck like you really really like me in
this video I could just feel it it was
written all over the video do you think
that's like a fair representation of
what you've been going through it's
really back true
I've hate no not hated birds in my eye
is true I'm trying to you forget the
other stuff I'm trying to cling on to
same it don't exist anymore
cuz I mean fact is true making that fear
video like that we've loved every minute
and I was proud of it recently what the
other videos I'll make a video I thought
I'll show it to anyone cuz I'm not I'm
not
it seems like I'm so poets look it's my
best work if I'm essentially doing it to
take over the time online do daddy so as
a fun this is your as your million fun
but as well because I'm not hopeful
in my opinion you're at the right of the
[__] top of the heap in terms of
talent there's not many people who are
funnier more charismatic who can do as
many different things you can edit
you've got you can do music there's
nothing you can't do but I feel like
you're like you need to be inspired
again by something you want to make it
edgy about yeah it's good that this feel
things came along but like equally I'm
interested as a fan I think what is
going to be the next year yeah yeah that
sparks you and they're like well I was
wondering me videos about this thing or
whatever literally like um and that's
the thing man I've let you been waiting
I've felt like this for a good while
like a couple of years
I'm not joking and I'm waiting for that
thing and it's like I'm not even waiting
I've been trying to searching and then
we start to force it then you start to
like are you over doing you're over
trying and that's okay I take a step
back or not I haven't uploaded in like
two weeks I what am I going to do and
it's just all the world you're getting
all these people soon in the background
oh well that's not the same as yeah in
deciding you're sort of it's a vicious
circle in it hmm no man it's like and I
honestly is at a point where I'm just
like I don't know what to do apart from
just keep searching keep trying
I [__] respect that honesty in there
because there's a lot of youtubers out
there and this isn't a not on them but
they just churn up the same old [__] and
and when you've got a million plus
followers and all that who want a video
from you this isn't what we're not
sickness in our poorest for youtubers
and it's a hard life not it's just
difficult at times because you've got a
lot of people you want to make happy
they want your videos and you want to
give them videos yeah but to get from A
to B something's [__] challenged
because you're like if I want to make
something I'm proud of and some people
out they just want any old video and
it's yeah do you want to be a youtuber
there's a choice of do I want to be a
youtuber associa for the money to just
churn out the regular videos that they
want what do I want to be someone who
gets that boards that were talking about
and gets because for me personally when
I do a great podcast I feel like I'll be
[__] smashed it yeah it's the best
feeling and I've never really got off
for making my own videos before because
I wasn't that proud of them you can
really tell they're you're saying in
front of two perfectionist yeah like you
two have got one approach to making your
videos which is I mean they're going to
make
you I'm not going to make a video and
there are so many people who would sort
of see this is all part of the process
and they're not affectionate when I met
him we were talking we were like it was
at the when we thought we were just
doing shoots and I was sitting down next
year and I was like you know when you're
wanting to make a video on that there's
something we just got a few days and
you're like that's kind of [__] meat
when I need to be like I need to really
want to do something about like they're
not me and you just got him because I
thought I'm so consumed with my brain
works as very similar yeah it's hard
because being a perfectionist it's great
if you feel like you've hit your target
because you feel like I've [__]
nailed this and many times you have but
on the flip side of it when you do and
you beat yourself up with out with 10
things more what maybe at 8 or 10 video
or still a [__] good video or
whatever but in your head it's still
[__] - or for 10 minutes there's
actually a really good TED talk about
creativity and it's by the woman who
wrote and don't take this as an
endorsement of the book I've never edit
Eat Pray Love I don't know what my name
is extinct but it's a it's probably when
I when I first graduated I watch this
and was I I didn't feel very inspired to
make videos because I was working on as
a runner on set and like felt like I'm
never going to get out one I was really
interested well you're going to get
coffee and like you just do whatever
anyone wants you to and she tells some
really good stories about how different
like cultures and generations see
creativity and she come which which
thing or it was but there was a singer
who was a guitarist in a band and in the
car he was driving along and apparently
heard like a riff in his head and it was
a good riff but he said like he had
nowhere to write it down so it was like
just [__] off and go to someone else and
he said like that was really empowering
because he was just like I suddenly felt
like I could I didn't have to worry
about guitarists coming to me and he'd
just tell me like if I wanted them to
[__] off or whatever there was another
woman that she tells a story about she
claims that like poems would come on the
wind to her and like that she would get
like poems that would come through the
wind and she write them out as they like
came through the wind and what is
interesting about our generation is
we put all the pressure of creativity on
the individual so you you maybe even me
if I make a video whereas there are
other cultures where it was about the
word genius used to be associated with a
little thing which you were blessed with
and it wasn't yours
it was just happened to be there and now
genius is inside the person and we put
all that pressure on the person as
opposed to the pressure being elsewhere
and I just often wonder like huge I mean
it's in the name is YouTube you know I
mean like how much of that is healthy
for people who are trying to create
really good videos and how much could
people at YouTube and the people
watching them be helping to take the
pressure off those people so they can
make better videos or not even take the
pressure off just change where the
pressure is it's quite deep shipment
absolutely none of it we monetize these
additional thoughts I'll take that all
the time so yeah yeah like I'm taking
that whole YouTube label art as a thing
like youtuber but then I like what is a
YouTube I feel like Joe sugg is that you
textbook youtuber consistent on it good
with the fan base sick videos like yeah
YouTube alarmed I just don't think I
just don't think I'm that lot I'm not
just that liking that well I'm not even
that at all I don't even look like
they're like I'll be like oh I just as a
point now where you hear that many
comments you actually get in there
before they do yeah I'm edgy isn't it
I'll get it there before the hey I'll
just but I basically what you don't feel
like you fit the term youtuber I just
don't do I what is dying
I don't really interact what I like
about you is that you're [__]
different though that's the good yeah
the good thing about you Janelle I mean
not everyone has to be the same name
where the lion you know these people but
you you're not one of them in my book
and you never happy yeah you just stick
out like a sore thumb when you're in
their company because they're the
beautiful people still amazed like the
nice guys but you are got an edge to
edge and I mean it makes you different
to them you would genuinely have a fight
with Jamie Carragher
or that would be a good boxing match
that won't be mad we have actually spoke
about em because I remember that mate
so quite vividly because I was
commentating on an antique nummy sell
[__] out I know Jordan and we would
genuinely fight this couldn't and I'm
not Jimmy Carter you would be was being
an out-of-order for a grown man kicking
lumps our kids really maybe it was the
biggest thing for me was when he'd been
marking us in a corner and he lit she'd
be like calling us a like effing c-word
like and stuff like that like in Oreos
what makes a charity match it's not in
six minutes of the game that what you do
is like Lydia he's just being Al Gore
and then when he starts like elbow and
faeo kicking me I'm not letting that
this ain't going on yeah and I yeah I
would so angry man I lost it I remember
stars on the bus he's just he had a
bottle that he was getting you were
[__] I was so they had a girlfriend
at the time god bless her soul and she
had to tolerate jaw like his eating like
because you know when you get really
pissed and you start eating but there's
no mana
so he's they just roll in the pit on
wanna ah like just write it up face your
[__] smashed but unfortunately you
were split up with her
yep they're girly to do err the
wrestling video s yeah oh yeah what's
the shim hmm she seemed like a nice girl
yep so you say no yeah oh justice when
you realized it may be not meant for
each other have it always one of those
things you know one of those things you
don't really uncomfortable name is just
like what he said he's bell on the
bottle I'm sorry
right there basically I what about Jimmy
Corrigan yeah well like there's my Jimmy
Corrigan um no I look okay
he obviously the next play football done
it oh yeah respect that as an actual man
see that absolute [__] and I've been
through the way the way we behave and
I'd like it the way he behaved as DG
I'll never forget about her awful awful
but what would you say if you were a dad
and your son was playing in the charity
football match and Jimmy Carrie I was
doing that the Osun what would you say
that's the thing like you just because I
was looking at this from that point of
view it's like you and my dad
not really but like it's a big brother
so yeah to me were like if he touches
you I was like I wasn't impressed like
because I actually liked him as a pundit
yeah what a [__] nob gone on like that
yeah I wasn't expecting at all blah look
I he called me out as well he doesn't
give a [__] because my favourite bit of
the whole bottle well what to fear of it
one will you manage to get him introduce
you was a great new signing in a Chelsea
show which was bunda and two when you
put a picture of his face in a dipascali
saying you would be this month yes you
said like he is clearly on drugs he did
look like it was obviously yes obviously
he wasn't using drugs when I had came
that either No so anyways not advocating
okay Rox I'm not saying you're on drugs
never burn your life um and then what
what do you talk to him what Tara go
yeah well have you ever had a little
chat bottle yeah I've had a bit of a
chat with him again I get so love to but
a lot I would love to I just chose with
a video like look at the view about to
match against character would be y'all
you'll get brutalized
I mean Keira good character so you do
you think it baby if I'm honest yeah if
I don't let's see how we get on with
feel and then judge him on that
genuinely Jamie Carragher is a cut
Scouse bastard like yeah yeah he would
rip he brick anyone's head in this room
no I think I think I like this room
though I said after he worships him look
why don't worry because you're excited
no no I can open generate the man and in
a fight he do me yeah watching box and
I'll say often get involved in I think
it's okay
he's cadiz them I can yeah Rick there we
got it yeah I don't reckon we can this
crappy do you know I mean yeah yeah yeah
do you think it was at all that he came
along and he was like I'm gonna show
these already know that little I reckon
he did the classic the reason cuz he
single eat signal me out from the get-go
he did ya know it's a classic thing that
legend I've had 90% wallet so much
through my life is the way people look
at me and instantly assume on a massive
prick right because of how I look
muscles with [__] like I could tell in
there you just wanted to kick me it was
from the first minute man literally yeah
and I'm like were you scared of that
when you when you know I wonder more how
about come on
yeah I piss me off I was like what are
you doing no you are you man actually
were giving it that I was trying to wind
him up right anyway what was so that
wasn't a great celebrity meeting what
was it like meeting the rock or video or
the rock has incredibly obviously like
that's an idol of mine tonight
very well you look rustling yeah yeah so
like seeing him firstly it's just the
wild factor plot ocbn achieve your
massive communities Matt well yeah it's
not as big as me is he not no no you
know he's probably taller than me but
taller be wait up imma give nice know
what we could do with jewel box and much
you as same as a nicety Jamie Carragher
daddy oh yeah you against Cara got me
against the rock we will get it on but
anyway what does he like say you are
poor you
yeah but he 6:05 anyways he was he had a
last master think throughout like
obviously he'd been doing press all day
we were the last of the day and spill
and I had the planner about him about
him and he he joined anybody connected
he engaged was like I feel like a lot of
celebrities made two starts fresh air he
fully got involved and I saw like I felt
like afterwards because just boom for
like a few drinks with the boys but
honestly that's a good inaudible I hit
when you hear like a celeb near like
someone of you think beyond those guys a
dick in real life so yeah it's what I've
seen the Gomez or mere you had a selfie
with her than you you can see in your
face both Helia both just like oh my god
what did you smell yeah I might not
honestly like she was your eyes have
changed right now because like the
finger vitality didn't touch double come
she face it now it o Bakula rien up it
is a yeah I don't Lauren tomatoes but
what was weird is actually he was going
to take she's bigger than you yeah she
those who toy but she was at yeah again
so nice baby I fell in love you know I
know it sounds so classic but like you
know I know you see them in your like oh
my god I figured like you read to be
Mario's know I know those who propose
not severely we were getting
yes what you proposed of course he will
yeah I just wanted to hear the right
seed a loader no way that I know I'm
gonna cry tonight he does she does loads
of charity gigs you know she does before
she's with the weekend knows and she or
someone that that's what a rube yeah
yeah
Nellie it's probably more of a chance
for that reason than you although she
was also adjusting be this oh yeah
you're a bit like a BTech Bieber on yeah
Lorien to Bieber BTech whaler
oh yes that maybe I actually feel like
he's actually like you know the mindset
that we were talking about earlier I do
feel like he's that I don't know why oh
yeah like oh that's so creative quality
of life and don't oh dude yeah lies do
not need to budge creatively I don't
know why run label everyone mug him off
bar things like do you think you have to
hard rough I don't know I think he'd
okay alright he's a life is that
absolutely I think when you're selected
your seem to be like selected as like
the guy everyone sort of is hoping you
[__] it up along the way
get Wiggly you're a bit like that
suppose you're a bit like that on
YouTube yeah but no one selected Joe the
people selected Joe you know one of my
YouTube well I'll take this one and play
marked you know I'm here hmm clear solid
definitely help you but we've already
talked yet is no one can I mean let's be
honest you stopped everyone yeah he's
like that YouTube's crutch yes he also
we've all only nine oh yeah good yeah
yeah it came up on it I mean I'll just
come up with it no so what's your
day-to-day life like now though okay so
obviously as a person I'm genuinely
wondering like what it is cuz I am
because everyone's complaining that
you're not making videos so what all you
do okay okay so I obviously the Fitness
is being nice did you take an over like
it's gone from being like a side thing
and I let you do it all the time I'll
see those are follow me on Instagram or
things like that like I'm sorry to pose
that sort stuff cuz I that's it's you
what I'm doing and yeah like why not why
not make videos build up then it's not
to approach yeah but as well just what
you say that we we record lychee almost
every other night there in this haunted
stuff but like when we got when we don't
get a successful video or like we don't
even if nothing happens if we don't
necessarily get good banner or anything
like that luck I just don't put it out
so many times a little going to film and
obviously when pop on top of that when
I'm like trying to do these old videos
and trying to like cut from the site
that really doesn't exist getting
frustrated obviously I put those videos
out so it's just a lot of my trying to
do something failing try not to force it
and then I'm not making anything you
know I mean that vicious circle that you
said if you haven't thought of live
streaming those ghost things ah but
would yeah yeah but it stays I like the
crit I like having like their their
creative ways yeah where I can create
that vibe through the cut through there
what I've shown what comes after but I
like that I feel like otherwise you're
just walking around a building like it's
just one take it's just literally like
you as scared is the first building do
you still get out absolutely and that is
the problem as well with the point stuff
that I've chosen I'm developing into a
bit of an expert right I asked my good
no that's not good a little bit the
entertainment comes when your stairs
yeah you know I mean and now you're not
saying for now walking I'm like come on
my mates calling out the devil every
five minutes brilliant but I lived you
know it's just like we gave it's become
less of like we're not on recovery where
yeah I mean that way actually I'm going
to say what about this all about I start
inviting other youtubers along who are
scared yeah I mean uh yeah lot I did
speak I think only a few videos yeah you
do look the podcast so kids like I sleep
in today G he's up first thing I'm
eating dead she says he'll do a lot of
things no not one yeah and yes it's a
nice it was busy he was buying the house
one week and then use a shotgun over the
next few minutes farm
let him crack on the anymore yeah we'll
get them on soon sorry
geez some yeah but now yeah that's the
only welcome thing to mix that up like
start incorporating other pineal and
Blair to the global in combination it's
also when though you least expected
that's when ghosts appear so maybe
you're getting towards that point now
where a ghost will sure maybe I mean
whatever I don't even know what what
even are like lies in hat like how do
you get into a beer so I thought I just
thought maybe not that's why history
goes on maybe you need got the wrong
camera
maybe I'm us what
about the idea they not just because you
can't see everything doesn't mean it's
not actually they're solving like right
that [__] for YouTube isn't it well yeah
but you just saying you know it might be
there there may be enough to less than
make because we just or not do it have
you ever thought of maybe mixing it up a
little bit like taking a team of people
to you know it worked really well with
your family do not I mean yeah that
again yeah I mean like I like to switch
up and do saying in the investigation no
can mix it up but I feel like the better
videos come when it is like with a
dynamic of one it is just two people it
is just that much more scarier yeah and
it's like and if something does go wrong
to people getting out of it like when
it's a big group it's like that yeah I
miss it will turn the lights on until no
you're all right yeah fine you're gonna
pretty much so like obviously yet is but
then like in with like the spirits and
ghosts stuff you have other things like
aliens and different conspiracy theories
that maybe we could start like believing
happening to a hundred then right oh
yeah yeah
aliens exist okay you begin the club I'm
not striking a table is I mean ask we're
doing conspiracy theories on a podcast
sometime soon well actually yeah also we
can't talk about no no we can stop Italy
why do you believe in aliens I think
that - yes alike I think those aliens
exist in the universe without a doubt
yeah do you think aliens exist within
this universe within this plague on the
planet sort of thing a little bit is no
but I mean like there may be other
universes that things exist in you know
I mean you could say in all of existing
infinity yes there's a god only not that
is that is realities but within this
galaxy do you think may there there
there and then within the you know water
on the moon of bloody Sutton and things
of that in the chances are others there
might be like bacteria there so that
technically clusters an alien as no all
of us so I guess so there's another
living organism in this universe
probably but pointing it would be there
would be a bit disappointing it was just
a little more it would be a real twisted
I was thinking of where did I get that
stereotypical image of an alien from it
must be from somewhere I
imagination right
from the FBI that the FBI originally
disseminated certain images and then
after it was only after the FBI started
telling people this is how aliens look
that people started going seen Halley's
was there's some people out there who
are like a theory that we are the aliens
like bringing human yet human beings are
bred from aliens basically that they
kill that's how intelligent I don't know
how there's many people with many
theories but I heard so many where like
they went and had sex with [__] the
Apes and [__] and this is how humans
came around right yeah I mean obviously
it doesn't really tie in with the theory
of evolution it's a theory nonetheless
I'm just saying yeah I mean now just
because I'm saying it doesn't mean I
believe that I just want to make it
clear yeah then you kid just to be very
clear we don't have you sectioned but
there are also people who think humans
aliens do you so that's that's quite a
spiritual way of looking at aliens that
you know I mean like quite a sort of
holistic approach well in a weird way
when I first heard that theory I kind of
like thought myself well we don't really
look like [__] and no else on this
planet we certainly don't act like
nothing I look like we literally look
like gorillas
oh look identical the [__] girl I
mean maybe I do but you don't do you
know I'm saying no but you know when you
look at I mean when you look at a face
of an this is often what happens is a
guest it's in the middle of Brian and I
have you but I mean there's a gorilla in
our any time when you see their face you
they give you certain looks near like I
see that you know I mean I mean yeah
that so like would you say you could be
yeah we can look like we can look at a
dog and feel like there's a relationship
there and there's a similarity I know
look at the dog and think that dog
shares the face of my great aunt you
mean funny but do you think that when
you look at a nip I don't know what your
great aunt looks like Boethius
she was a very very important to me to
look at I'll get it out all right class
yeah 15 yeah I mean we don't talk about
anymore and what do you think about that
theory but we maybe the aliens ah little
[__] you know I mean as well as if
well it doesn't believe it then I don't
believe it well I can't fall for it it
definitely and a you spiritual person do
you pray do you soon ah no I wanna go
get a one let it are on that cuz like
one minute I'm like yeah
no drawing I was in the nation it's just
like violent like of its sunny I'm great
he's actually quite true you're the
winner if you are someone if they
believe in God they're like now I didn't
exist middle of summer is God's great I
just go I really think that do you think
there is a there is a God but that man
is not a classic Bible representation of
God but a greater power it's gotta be
star that's what everyone says but like
yeah there's something is there I don't
know at the end of the day I do feel
like there's if you have to bet on it
Oh mate not and this is actually look
this what they say you know how it's
light in my head right now that since
you what they say yeah that's right
because you'll never be able to like
concede it like actually decide do you
um but okay so I'm not really out of the
math God or whether you believe in God
because obviously that's that's tricky
to you from a sponsor point Lee as well
um do you do anything in your daily life
which you think makes you more relaxed
and more spiritual like do you you know
meditation I think I think that Jim is
the main thing like yeah 100% because
it's release of frustration it's just
like getting your engine going which
then I just think it hundred percent if
I didn't do that I'll be well over the
place Pharisee and yeah obviously
recently while I've been trying to sit
down for the summer I was been eating
better and I feel like that as well I am
has its benefits like in terms of
keeping your head what I'm sorry
so recomendation to give cuz we've got a
lot of lunch I want to get a better ship
like you're in good shape so what can
you advise the reader okay lob a semi
average day is this so often the gym in
the morning fasted gym sessions with and
all food no food before the gym I
weighed in because so I'm using up all
the calories from last night but there
were in my stomach
yeah if they're thrilled if I was still
in my system and I see if there's no
nothing Madden is burning straight for
to the fat then obviously after that I
have chicken and it's like weird small
that they do at this light health place
near me baby chicken salad nice yes with
like a very breakfast yeah Oh a 10 we've
just our fruit and vegetable juices you
know where they pressed you like that I
make the juice so it's like
natural and then later on like a protein
bar but a decent one like so many of
them are just they might as well be a
mars bar basically yeah it needs to be
one it's as you'd be since the way
decent I do I'm not sponsored grenades
protein bars and they have good you an
effective I find them effective yeah
yeah and then throughout the day just
actually proteins eggs protein fruit
boating veg I literally cut carbs but
that's not the mic that's not that's not
the safest way to go about it because
like you do need some so like there may
be like every so someone's just starting
out you would recommend like porridge
and roast some stuff if you're cutting
if you're cutting fat you need to cut
carbs right in fact but it may be like
every three days you have a meal with
like you may have oats or something like
that like to give your body some clubs
to operate but then otherwise instead of
bone of fact it's just going to use the
clubs and me it's going to say the same
like bait Lesley Suter fact I think that
this is one thing where you should
really go into am open for a YouTube
channel because II and I'm going to be
completely honest it's a passion of
yours yeah whatever you love something
that's what you need and also you can
make a [__] ton of money getting
sponsored by some hair protein company
yeah because an eight well thanks
honestly I will take grenade a day that
these these protein sponsorship
companies are paying people fortunes
like my protein and all that all the UFC
fighters are norms I mean you've got
massive audience you guys are going to
listen this well a protein bars or maybe
I'm a real brand wanna do your own
company me there you go yeah well I
would like to say thing as well you know
you mentioned intense walking yeah poor
guy that's what I do that's what I do
for cardio if the best one way you a
monkey del but I was like yeah poppers
like you're entirely correct I know it
not become is the idea of you something
yeah I'm feeling like shut up Lord so
what else would it go it's about seven
girls seeing is the idea of bloom 10
what it does work doesn't it copy
abdication ability muscle tissue you've
just yeah great ones if you go to
intense what your body's like oh [__] I
need to like conserve all the fat and
concern for kids in because I like a gym
in
yeah hiking so I think watch out because
there's so much talking what's that one
oh well that one much appreciate was
that one for the rich 700 recent one
that sure bro yeah so it could intense
walk and will that be up a hill or sort
of are you like 90 no no no I'm trying
because I realize yeah that's again what
am I talking about your intended walk
none of that so basically I switch
between to an uphill in pencil shuts out
there Jabra really little things they
say the way he walks his walk is a run
me I'm not even joking his rates trigger
push got big stride it's just funny did
he literally bouncing were there anymore
like every every foot look I'm a [__]
basketball trainer every thread is a
[__] bones go over that or the spec
machine alright son I don't yeah
and I understand that I'm not taking the
page it's just funny generally we'll say
oh the book look there it is yeah what
would you say Lawrence needs to do in
order well I mean less yeah elbows I
mean they just do it dirty bulk they
just have as eat as much you can
yeah straight low you don't do that what
cuz then you end up looking a bit like
no it means I'm not whoa whoa you I mean
like now I mean like you is like you can
poke someone it's like I literally think
I think that as well but I'm little wise
you're not looking like but what I mean
look it depends on every that's what I
say it depends on your body type because
if you're an EXO morph naturally like
really tall and lean like a thing oh
yeah I'm not puttin on weight putting on
muscle is like so hard you have to eat
loads of calories it is to the point
where just like like where we are cannot
really say because the reason why I say
that bonkers well is because it or gild
you get bored of having just weight gain
a protein shakes now in it the yeah you
know I mean you need to have that
balance of where you can actually keep
this up consistently yeah well yeah most
people do that where like they they put
a lot of muscle on and that we for a
very short space of time they look good
and then let's go back to looking at
absolute [__] yeah often used to work in
one of those stores you know whether
guys how it looks the way they look
those guys who then take the t-shirt
forever in the front of the store your
men told them to do a book on benefit
yeah so when she was a teenager share
that one those weekend jobs now anyway
so in that store these guys just beat my
whole chickens in between just going out
there and chatting to girls I just
sounded [__] awful yeah horrible yeah
that's the thing and that's what the
girls are meeting chickens on me widow
soon to be fair she used to topless in
the front door there would be a very
different effect in Abercrombie oh yeah
I do feel like a lot of people have that
idea that I if I eat clean it is just
like starving myself of everything I
enjoy and like no that is that you feel
bad
no that's the way to fail because you're
not going to keep it up right it needs
to be that balance like that sense of it
but like on my chicken salad I have
pesto and mustard mayo right really
silly I shouldn't do that very nice but
it's not too bad and it's not I wouldn't
otherwise I mean I I would not eat a
voice without faith in those ways to
beat the system yes your mind is going
to want to brick especially when you're
like me and you and emotional for those
because I don't know about you but if I
feel done like bad food makes us feel a
bit better but then it but then
afterwards I make shouldn't have is no
worse shut up but you know I mean like
if you can find a way to cheat it mmm
they find something that you like but
nice honest solid and that's a good have
an intense walk to McDonald's but I have
a sizable yes matyoo
even mugging it on such a condors and
yes I'm not supposed to say that what
I've been told not see well no I Arlen
because I probably put sponsors off but
you are such a [__] crying oh that's
good see you there yeah
thanks for coming we've got some
questions from your phone to record
golfers yeah yeah let's take an intense
walk through those questions my question
for young Joseph is this is worth of it
have you ever watched anime porn PS get
a feared haircut next time here at the
barber we well it's not a little bit
faded yeah a jelly anyway quite hard
factor for Nia yes or no obviously I
don't on offending on bar can not
understand how anyone can watch that
right was not offensive it's alright
mother is it no well I could not like
something I'm so yeah you know in real
life it is just like I wouldn't kill a
number one
very general who framed roger rabbit
yeah just like a rabbit all right
remember human being like I don't know
why but she makes me feel funny right
like I didn't really know what I was
thinking yeah you've never felt that way
about once I loved it I was like no I
was about six seven years old but I just
remember thinking there's something I
like about her but I don't really know
what I mean I mean you've had some
intense my personal around seven years
okay just wait I mean all before me tell
you but [__] me only means win well so
people like most of it over cartoons yes
so I just want to be clear whatever you
can Eminem I was going to do it would be
Jessica rather what is reality then what
it's that's the thing like okay at
either the question no I thought I don't
offend people I don't think it's a
failure both people Photoshop things I'm
sorry submitted you might as well to
draw a dash line of the sidemen do you
get along with the most favorite members
plaguing all the larger one on holiday
will include that in as well
other than an assignment but just all
the larger one on hold is anyone who you
get on with bare ah best chip
the bone chip Josh he violates he's so
funny you give him one of your truck
suits or whatever you go I go Texas you
know you and Elliott or balls get in the
same line
ah third one oh yeah felt quit third
wheel tracksuit yeah nan a beard [__]
most embarrassing moment is there
anything you can think of but if I I've
got a big ass snapchat you John
ah I think the girl was more bounce than
he was to be so now that would be I was
a full-blown walk assume that she can we
include that oh yeah I mean we can now
really sorry okay um I'm on a sport beta
D if I have accidentally sent any of
those to someone else in their mo smoke
yeah you would have been pissed at the
time I'd imagine just clicking like all
the people you're going to send it to
well I sent it to you yeah you got a
damning name you got it who haven't
there wasn't for us here watching
entrance music for the big box and macho
you picked NES oh it's gotta be
copyright free which is a dead thing but
I wanted to go to something I basically
think
what represents me and it's gonna be
that right comment down below what so
you think represents me are we gonna get
fluent oh well there's some youtubers
out there who you [__] hit is there
anyone out there you really really
really hit aah
we are you home Oh
basically Matt I don't hate anyone but
are we talking about I don't like their
content not just youtubers who piss you
off or whatever um anyone whose content
you don't know
wait it's like you already know that
don't okay
they want to know uh okay now look I
will just say the ones that like
realistically are just doing it to be
like a face in our aisle everyone look
at me like I love the attention rather
than possessing like talent and some of
that that obviously I'm not like I don't
hate them but is he not I I prefer those
that maybe are pursuing a graft of some
sort rather than so that's respectable
that's exactly what I sort of have a
problem with your food since you're not
that active on YouTube so much something
back on the back Pam so aggressive I was
in are there any big plans for the
future like is there anything that you
think in long term hmm no that that well
there it is obviously like obviously I
want to continue like growing the stuff
and like experiencing new things but in
terms of saying oh yeah I've got a song
coming up there's one thing there's not
one thing that it's not a specific thing
I'll go where I can say oh yeah this is
coming this date apart from OCD boxing
fight yeah that's a big thing that's a
big fight that of do you usually
remember your dreams in the morning uh
yeah oh my god is there any of them
that's together when I stand on it no
right
what would you there are well then what
is the one that sticks out in particular
well no obviously never you guys
obviously what like I just come to be
like oh yeah we're cribs about actually
sugar this [__] as the word it wasn't
Selena Gomez there was it now like is
this been variously well in a lie
there's this biology teacher from school
we're gonna get really that GUI I was
fine
what why it's quite fit yeah they're not
really for well-off family yeah why are
you so sexist
Oh partly this is like in relation to
the basketball video it is vaping did he
pin that girl down on a basketball
course and they let that heart from the
fact that was just what we were dinner
challenge where we're both in one pair
of shorts and it's about what like you
have to but get the ball I dribble it
would both of you and getting the balls
I wasn't sexist sorry how's that sexy
consensual love it I don't think it's
all that you said that as you push me
over ever more how I mean I've got them
here that replied to you but I'm still
maybe that come across the wrong way
maybe they felt like you in LA it should
have shared some shorts girl [__] just
to make it ma'am if we all want to be
equal then come on what that to show you
there shouldn't be an issue is consumed
Allison I'm sorry that they can do it
they want when Chelsea and Brighton
clearly overseas Brian you're supporting
Brighton I'm learning honestly I support
both teams fact I open we've talked here
look but but right now your item but
purely because they are don't the
closure time they are like you know I
mean maybe a Brighton play a Newcastle
how did you win the title app I'll start
with a tricky aside you a couple of
tricks on that last ever season as a
limit of that [__] when you castle play
Brighton I'll make sure I'll get a watch
up with you
alright we'll find a way to meet up okay
all right all right
what is the nicest thing anyone's ever
done T there's anything that sticks I
really sight my mum's done isn't it but
not allowed to do your mum anyone else
on your mum because we know your mom's
an angel you'll see that okay um I'm a
I'm tonari no I just thought i JJ to
cook
day so please I took us on holiday but
all of us lads till I'm sick thing
where'd you go uh.what Magaluf one year
i annapolis and i yeah real oppose them
the invitation are more than happy to
come think yeah right i was it your
fault that we weren't involved in the
Seidman much
some people's calmer Saphira so I don't
want a conspiracy theory some people are
saying you made sure that we were the
comment ask you feel about stepping into
a warm grace yeah so listen that eyelid
she said I was like I want to do the
thing with to Jordy my words really just
needy initially you message me before
you smoke them and said I want to do the
commentary with you yeah so it wasn't
jaws fault I just want everyone to know
what oh yeah
so what was it again cuz that wasn't me
no okay no baby hang on oh well okay I
can ask you questions real real they
honestly though how did you find
commentating sweaty by like I just I
probably wasn't very good because I uh I
don't know man it's a lot to take in
because you're presenting a show or
simultaneously trying to like keep it
together and not swear
and then yeah it's a lot guys I get told
not a services yeah well I do I just
keep it down keep it down variable
unlike yeah because we went a bit I
don't think that's one of the reason why
you're kicked off could you swear too
much I never made I'm gonna be here
myself next year though I'm not gonna be
injured oh well them correctly funky
everyone is good it is job second choice
but ironically that's when our baby
knows it haha
there was a lot there with no
competition but they'll have to choose
you hear screw it
yeah unle it will do a great job on
commentary and actually that will be
really good what you a little baby off
by than month you know you'll be married
by then it's good another second series
a marriage series not anyone with
arranged marriages on MTV Elliott
mara Abraham Lincoln mark laughs my
niece another worker no I mean how long
does it mean to produce a song our
bloody ages make purely because when I
make them a lot I'm really just sitting
down in a studio constantly I'm working
with someone a different point in the
world at this there to make mission and
far from you that someone from Newcastle
and is that yet Georgia talent yeah so
lightly how we produce that is easier
over Skype cool so I have my software up
like I do bits deviants send the project
to him he do it send it back and we just
be doing it like that switch can take
ages because he's actually said of
school he's 15 years old Wow and he had
a honesty pure talent man so obviously
he's doing school I'd be doing a show
about love oh yeah I didn't even say his
name
MB 13 beats yeah yeah on his shorted
point because look I do it look it up
for me on yeah there you go of that I'm
not a normal question have you ever
tried anal sex yes I know no receiving
or giving laughing okay who are you good
to have you well odd this apparently and
you under the pitch in the FA Cup final
saying that it was going to be an easy
win for Chelsea in yeah I got mugged off
that Naz gives it a big in on the f80
new saying we're going to win five lil
lightly she kept saying over now begin
5-nil marked my way and I got Ballad
quarter perfume did that FA to be picked
ero I was a free yeah yeah charge I did
she's not a thing I said to them I was
like look yet like they had all this
unreal like plan and a creative idea and
they did it but I was like look why
didn't you get like like pay a bit get a
budget get like the Cybermen guys
involved get a whole bunch of us
involved we will talk about this on the
last podcast where I mean go and check
it out of fear that you're one of fun we
do good podcasts on illness as well out
but I wanted to see TV companies to work
with for youtubers or a [__] bullet
or who visit me yeah they don't really
listen to what you've got to say that I
cause it's silly little youtuber all
right go on and humbly me on the paper
show yourself yes I don't have me having
to be here yes is evident Isis is no
religion I do actually work for a living
you [__] I'm not a lover who is very
well swim you walk like that towards you
don't be like wake up [__] four and a
half million subscribers for a reason
you know and you know piss mate epitome
up to the desert is there anything all
right what do you got any last questions
Lawrence about little walking all right
now no no no the same ask your question
I will ask it again because I know
you're all getting older your tunes
they're different and so I'm wondering
how would you like to be remembered
Ohio rubra I someone who is integral
like does not do [__] because they're
told to or because people want them to I
mean that crap yeah literally successful
for being myself
alright me I hope you've got that for
the record I don't give a [__] what
anyone says I think you're on the latest
rather than yeah we right agree I'm
risking largely if you enjoyed this and
show you like the [__] video check
well as channel oh if you are one of our
subscribers are links to that are in the
description below and also make sure you
subscribe to this channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching and we'll
see you as well